non
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous pour cette fin d'année
nous sommes dans l'hémicycle du
département
nous fêtons ce soir la création les
créateurs d'entreprises des
entrepreneurs des gens qui font bouger
la réunion alors bienvenue dans la 19ème
édition du challenge des créateurs
d'entreprise
[Musique]
plus d'une centaine de candidats 12
finalistes et six lauréats ce soir ce
challenge était un concours récompense
et qui récompense le parcours des
créateurs d'entreprise autour de six
thèmes
alors on va vous présenter ces thèmes
l'insertion la création d'emplois
l'innovation la performance le produit
pays et enfin le prix du jury
bref la vie des entreprises et pour nous
en parler nous recevons ce soir nassimah
dindar bonsoir ça la présidente du
département pourquoi le département
accompagne ses porteurs de projets
parfois éloignées de l'emploi
parce que d'abord je pense que quand on
les accompagne ils ont bien plus de
chances de réussir et que le chômage ça
n'est pas une fatalité
le réunionnais est entrepreneur 4600
création d'entreprise sur les neuf
derniers mois ça monte effectivement la
créativité du réunionnais l' envie de
réussir et il nous donne parfois envie
de croire en lui
c'est ce que nous faisons au conseil
départemental nous croyons en la
possibilité qu'ont les jeunes comme les
moins jeunes à créer leur entreprise à
réussir et à créer de l'emploi et de la
richesse pour la règle alors cette
énergie positive où elle voir ce soir
c'est ce que nous allons présenter
autour de ce nouveau cru et avant
d'arriver à ces douze finalistes
nous avons eu un spip casting s'était
organisé au village corail un bel
endroit d'ailleurs ou pour réunir les
candidats les futurs créateurs
d'entreprise
[Musique]
et 130 candidats en lice pour cette
19ème édition du challenge des créateurs
des chefs d'entreprise qui ont à coeur
de défendre leurs activités et leur
savoir faire
ils ont envie le dossier ce que me
représente non pour avoir envie de se
faire connaître
on a envie d'élargir son réseau on a
envie aussi bandes de montrer ce conflit
on est quand même contents de ce qu'on
fait on lance le spi de casting édition
12 jury constitué d'experts en création
d'entreprise vont auditionner tous les
candidats un speed casting de huit
minutes pour faire la différence et être
sélectionné parmi les finalistes
quand on dit que le réunionnais n'a pas
d'idée c'est faux moi je trouve qu'au
contraire on a une bonne idée on a
beaucoup de valeur on a beaucoup
d'humanité on a beaucoup de choses qui
sont mises en valeur et c'est l'occasion
de découvrir ces jeunes talents cette
année particulièrement on a des projets
innovants en termes vraiment donc
d'idées nouvelles de développement
durable et de technologie
[Musique]
à la fin de ce speed castine ils ne sont
plus que douze 12 finalistes qui vont
devoir défendre leur projet dans les six
catégories récompensées par le challenge
des créateurs
prochaine étape les batteurs
[Musique]
voilà après le speed casting j'ai eu la
chance avec l'équipe de 9 7 4 tv et de
rencontrer chacun des candidats ils sont
juste là les 12 finalistes
mais évidemment il a fallu les
départager ça s'est passé il ya quelques
jours avec les membres du réseau pour un
chance
[Musique]
mais ça a été très compliqué parce qu'en
réalité tous ces participants
il symbolise la diversité réunionnaise
et puis on a aussi essayé de primes et
l'originalité des projets parce que ça
semble intéressant de photographier un
instant donné
cette réunion qui montre l'exemple bref
l'excellence réunionnaise challenge des
créateurs c'est pas seulement un
concours ordinaire de projets
entreprenariale c'est un concours de
ceux qui ont galéré et qui sont dans la
difficulté il dit chan dans le dur et
qui à un moment donné ils veulent s'en
sortir encore plus que les autres
je crois que c'est la volonté qui fait
la différence ce concours il vise aussi
à personnes persuadées chacun chacun de
ceux qui nous regardent ce soir qui sont
dans la difficulté que oui zac est
capable si alors bonne chance à tous les
participants ce soir
[Musique]
voilà une belle image nou lé kapab zot
lé capable on vous a présenté donc les
acteurs de cette belle soirée de
récompenses du challenge des créateurs
d'entreprise et maintenant on va vous
demande vous présentez savoir qu'est ce
qu'ils vont gagner les prix mais
bénéficieront de 5500 euros par le
département de la réunion ainsi que 500
euros de la part de pôle emploi
ils auront également accès un pack de
formation offertes par l'ordre des
experts comptables et la cgss ainsi qu'à
une adhésion de la ga plr le département
de la réunion est heureux d'offrir 1500
euros et une adhésion à la ga plr cgr
voilà de quoi faire du bien à une jeune
entreprise c'est parti maintenant pour
les différentes catégories
on commence par le prix de la sers
surtout pour nous en parler vigano
paillade ben hamida président de la
commission insertion solidarité active
et coopération alors l'insertion par
l'activité c'est la compétence
prioritaire du département via le coup
de pouce qui est connue vraiment de tous
les créateurs c'est laden est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer écouter en
fait laden correspond à une politique
très volontariste du département qui
souhaitent accompagner les ceux qui
osent aller dans l'aventuré de la
création d'entreprise
en fait il s'agit tout simplement d'un
prêt à taux zéro qui peut aller jusqu'à
8000 euros donc ce n'est pas rien et
avec la possibilité de bénéficier d'un
différé de remboursement
donc voilà ensuite ce dispositif il a
deux vertus qui sont très intéressantes
la première vertu c'est que le
dispositif mobilisant fait un réseau de
partenaires sur lequel le créateur va
pouvoir s'appuyer avec le réseau point
chance et donc le fait que ces experts
accompagne le porteur permet au projet
d'optimiser tous les financements qui
sont existants c'est à dire que le
créateur n'a pas besoin de justes
pousser la porte du département ils
peuvent venir par tous les acteurs du
réseau planches tout à fait et là on
arrive à la deuxième vertu de ce
dispositif qui correspond un
accompagnement durable
en fait le créateur il est accompagné
depuis la conception du projet avec la
boutique de gestion avec d'autres
d'autres partenaires et il est même
accompagné après donc en aval de
création puisqu'il bénéficie d'un
accompagnement post création qui est
financée bien sûr par le département
alors il faut pas se priver on est
jeunes créateurs ne vous privez pas à
créer mon entreprise pousser la porte
des membres du réseau pan chance alors
découvrons maintenant les deux candidats
en lice dans la catégorie insertion
[Musique]
l'association que moi et représente un
coût le parc créole dans l'avenir de la
région
[Musique]
l'un des créateurs je peux gagner c'est
6000 euros déjà et puis pour pouvoir
faire à laboratoire
[Musique]
alors stéphane cette entreprise comment
ça s'est passé ben l'entreprise alors
qu'un bébé s'appelle le carré d'as le
snack-bar carré d'as et emmène tout le
monde à venir voir mène à la jeunesse
mais aussi les anciens aussi bien là la
même arme à l'école dans le collège et
l'école primaire
n'allez pas vous aussi des lèvres que
les très content le moins il veut mettre
en avant les eaux surtout parce qu'ils
m'ont beaucoup beaucoup d'activités il
manque une cohésion sociale toutes deux
moulins peu dispersés dans notre
mentalité comme dit créole saissac un
point ce soir et certains points ce soir
les possibles tout le monde nous ainsi
rannou nou lé kapab donc nous fait pas
peur tout pourquoi stéphane donc qui
était auparavant d'emplois mais c'est du
rsa m était demandeur d'emploi m'avait
fini l'assedic ben grosse galère pour
trouver un emploi quoi tu es en espace
vert
emma chamboule tout m'a dit eh non il
faut me crée il faut il créer parce
qu'il ne peut rien et en criant
peut-être que ma emmène 2000 avec moins
dans la création envisage de mettre un
petit coin détente ses amis et aussi par
rapport que mais les finalistes elle a
déjà investi dans les habitudes
moi j'ai bien aimé le parcours de ceux
de stéphane j'ai bien aimé une situation
difficile en terme d'emploi en terme de
formation une création d'entreprise
plutôt réussi et puis en plus un lien
social j'ai bien aimé cet aspect des
choses et en même temps c'est quelqu'un
qui préparent l'avenir pour pouvoir
diversifier son activité avec des
grillades et donc augmenter son chiffre
d'affaires
[Musique]
bonjour comment allez vous bien alors
sony a raconté nous c'est quoi votre
activité que faites vous qui êtes vous
je suis artisan déjà au et artisans dans
café pour faire le café
j'exhorte le café j'ai créé mon activité
de bar ambulant de café bar ambulante
plus exactement ça fait environ deux ans
et le programme d'aujourd'hui alors
c'est quoi alors aujourd'hui on va aller
au marché des producteurs au théâtre de
saint-gilles où je les vends mes
boissons
[Musique]
raconte nous ton parcours en matière je
dirais social qu'est ce qui a fait que
tu aujourd'hui chez l'entreprise
auparavant tu fais qu'un statut avant
j'étais presque c'est mickaël enfin j'ai
été responsable ensemble d'appel j'ai
exercé pendant dix ans en région
parisienne puis je suis revenu à la
réunion et voilà j'avais vraiment besoin
de mettre toute mon énergie
parce que c'est un nouveau concept c'est
pas non plus un concept qui a été vécu
par les autres on n'a qu'une vie quoi et
je pense que si on a vraiment des bonnes
idées il y aura toujours les fonds
disponibles
sans la force de volonté on n'arrive à
rien et je pense qu'il faut vraiment le
vouloir
jamais lâché prise et croire en son
projet original
le concept la leçon concept vie du
visuel et technique
joli projet vente de café en ambulance
pour pouvoir promouvoir et savane la
réunion en matière de café mais pas
seulement
et donc voulons effectivement de pouvoir
s'en sortir pour elle et sa famille
[Musique]
on peut les applaudir ces magnifiques de
magnifiques projets ils sont là derrière
nous stéphanie n'a face l'entreprise de
carré d'as sony tati roumat les
entreprises le barista run tir où tous
qu on peut encore les applaudir c'est
magnifique ce qu'ils ont fait et leur
entreprise alors c'est la zone 2 de
libération cette zone là madame passé le
suspense je vous laisse annoncé le
lauréat de la catégorie insertion alors
le lauréat pour le prix de l'insertion
et madame sony ta tir ou mal et on
l'applaudît bravo bravo sony t'attire ou
mal et de l'entreprise le barista run
tire tout cas félicitations aux
visiteurs une belle victoire ça avant de
te interrogées ont peut-être regarder le
témoignage de ta maman elle était là
plutôt fière de sa fille c'est ça tu vas
t'en c'est une femme très courageuse
elle aime bien ce qu'elle fait donc à se
référer contente d'arriver
ce concours elle mérite donc vrai mérite
beaucoup cette fille elle bosse très
fier très calme active à ce que vous
avez envie de lui dire justement
et bien sony damas hama et deir el
t'encourage encourage je te suis
toujours bain jusqu'à la grande réussite
que ça raconte plein de choses tu as de
bonnes choses se dit ah je serai cadets
tout cas ma fille et elle va l'applaudir
bravo félicitations
la grande réussite on se bat tous les
jours pour ça oui toujours
on se relâche pas qu'est ce que ça
représente ce prix-là gagner avec tout
ce que ça représente au quotidien comme
engagement mains des sages la dédicace à
mon fils c'est important et c'est une
vraie continuité pour moi c'est un
nouveau souffle
j'en avais vraiment besoin et
aujourd'hui je pense que vraiment cette
histoire de laboratoire va voir le jour
et c'est une vraie extension est simple
entraînement ma marque
c'est une histoire folle qui commence à
prendre forme et je vais rien lâcher ça
c'est clair
magnifique bravo félicitations je
voulais ce prix chacun sa route chacun
son parcours et pour rapprocher le
public en difficulté de l'emploi le
département subventionne un contrat aidé
le service ait eu un exemple de contrats
aidés au port avec une maman courage
[Musique]
genre je m'appelle mohammad abdul des si
j'ai commencé ici ça fait à peu près un
mois et demi oui je suis en contrat
c'est lui c'est mieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mieux je perçois un salaire je vis
normalement allons pas du tout quand on
n'a pas de travail c'est difficile c'est
très difficile surtout quand on a des
enfants
[Musique]
ce type de contrat est subventionné par
le département encore plus souvent
saunier quand la personne est au rsa
le recrutement se fait par le pôle
emploi est actuellement en magasin on a
trois services le principe c'est que le
département aide le directeur la société
en fait est de mon côté pour j'obtiens
du travail voilà c'est gagnant gagnant
on y met du sien bien sûr c'est sûr il
ya un avenir pour la personne
moi personnellement j'ai commencé en cdd
et aux choix qui je suis je suis en cdi
intégrés dans la société
j'aimerais bien rester mon sac société
et par la suite par exemple retour dans
l'hémicycle pour cette deuxième
catégorie
mais cette 19ème édition du challenge et
créateurs d'entreprise
le sait maintenant le prix de la
création d'emplois avec mohamed fadel le
chargé de mission partenariat à pôle
emploi bonsoir ça alors ce sont des
petites entreprises
elle ne crée pas beaucoup d'emplois
parce que ça c'est dynamique a vraiment
un impact sur les chiffres du chômage
vous avez chaque année autour de 5 min
création d'entreprise à la réunion il
faut savoir que dans ces 5 min création
d'entreprise vous avez à peu près 30 à
40% selon les années qui sont portées
par des demandeurs d'emploi donc au
niveau de pôle emploi on a une vraie
volonté politique d'aller accompagner la
création d'entreprise et nous versons à
ce titre à peu près 7 millions d'euros
chaque année aux demandes non pas pour
les aider les accompagner vers cette
création là il faut pas avoir peur de
son petit projet alors il faut pousser
la porte c'est sale écoutez je crois que
tous les leviers d'action sont
importants en matière de création et la
par rapport aux témoignages que vous
venez de voir vous voyez très bien que
la volonté compte est vraiment il ya ce
qu'il faut à la réunion on a eu l'année
des projets très intéressants et je
crois qu'il faut s'appuyer dessus pour
que les gens voient et considère que
tout est encore bon tout est encore à
faire alors de couvron ensemble c'est
deux finalistes de la catégorie création
d'emplois c'est maintenant les deux
finalistes
[Musique]
- mon hobby c'était avoir travaillé
envoie l'entreprise quoi
forte de la compétition mais en
contraire c'est un défi
[Musique]
bonjour la chaleur nous attendons ça me
travaille un petit peu bienvenue dans
ton coin
pourquoi elle a pris sept entreprises
selon scott parcours annoncé travailler
à l'âge de 12 ans à 22 ans dont l'arôme
première entreprise
ça n'a pas tenu donc après c'est à 50,2
la roueyre ouvert mon entreprise je vais
dire oui me pense que mon un petit peu
plus jamais un peu plus d'expérience
du coup bon ben voilà passé un petit peu
aussi par pôle emploi
la boutique de gestion siat ou bien si
pas de diplôme pas de crp travailler sur
des chantiers et recréer un entreprise à
52 ans est déjà pas mal
arrivé alors
[Musique]
du coup vous avez combien de salariés
ici on est un simple ans et j'ai un
autre chantier retape il peut dérober
l'argent
comment vous faites j'ai passé par pôle
emploi du temps plus bas à cogner les
granotes et habiter travailler ensemble
depuis longtemps
donc voilà dit pourquoi pas créer une
entreprise pour faire connaître ces gars
là parce qu'il travaille bien dans ce
secteur il me semble que c'est un
secteur qui connaît la crise on crée une
forme basse et l'a fait remarqué parce
qu'il m'a frappé c'est sa capacité à ne
pas renoncer du son parcours
la force de caractère qui développe et
surtout son enthousiasme on va vous la
faire grandir encore son entreprise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais dans l'automobile en 98 donc
dans un société de lavage auto donc
ensuite j'ai travaillé pour automobiles
réunion pendant 12 ans plus le temps
passe et donc je me suis dis donc
pourquoi pas ouvrir et créer des emplois
trompé j'ai mis toutes mes économies
cette année donc on a décidé justement
de voir réunion entreprendre pour nous
aider justement pour eux avancé les
fonds pour eux des travaux
quand vous voyez aujourd'hui donc on
exactement dans nos futurs locaux et
combien d'employés des années cet
employé qui sont à temps plein qui sont
attendus je me donne vraiment à fond
pour faire avancer l'entreprise et si
les travaux risée les jeunes créent des
emplois justement c'est au bureau c'est
mon bol au leinster les projets de
recrutement à venir
on a des projets de recrutement
justement quand les locaux seront
terminés parce que décidera de mettre en
place de la mécanique justement ça sera
en début janvier les mets que la
mécanique l'egypte petite révision
plaquettes l'avenir positif c'est de
gagner justement le challenge pour faire
un peu des travaux dans les bâtiments
c'est un jeune chef d'entreprise est
très dynamique et sérieux comment c'est
une entreprise qui est bien positionné
sur son marché avec tous les bureaux cas
au tour avec beaucoup de clientèle une
clientèle potentielle
on ressent bien que la question des
emplois et une grande importance
[Musique]
applaudissez les ils sont là ce sont
vraiment des baux candidats des beaux
finalistes de la catégorie création
d'emplois on peut les applaudir encore
en fringues afghan entreprises gavaudan
wilfrid l'entreprise shine auto tous les
deux ils ont créé de plusieurs emplois
c'est vraiment magnifique
ça va mieux ça va liger vous en avez vu
d'autres j'imagine dans le monde de
l'entreprise pour vous écoute monsieur
patel pour cette année le prix de la
création d'emplois est décerné à
monsieur fred cav aux dents on
l'applaudît
félicitations à ces bons c'est une belle
image on peut l'applaudir au corps ça va
mais quelle grave at il eu respire
respire
est ce que le temps de vous laisser
prendre votre respiration peut-être voir
le témoignage de quelqu'un qui compte
pour vous qui vous accompagne au
quotidien
regardez pour son courage sa
détermination parce que le début a été
quand même difficile il a eu pas mal
d'embûches surtout bon appris quand on
dépend des marques comme ça
financièrement c'est pas facile tout si
les gages tout ce qui fait je viens là
dynamis ils font ce malgré les
difficultés il y va ça c'est voilà je
l'admirais pour tout ça et puis bon
voilà à 52 ans fond c'est comme ça je
cherchais du travail de bouger à droite
à gauche
embauché missaoui lui personne comme ça
en l'espace de deux mois je veux dire
c'est c'est quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de stress aussi parce que bon ben voilà
c'est celle où mois pour moi il mérite
moi cela me dire que c'est tout je
l'admiré c'est magnifique
bravo fed certains employés ont des
mages que vous la même expérience mais
pourquoi vous vous avez pris les rênes
pourquoi vous avez décidé je vais créer
mon entreprise je vais je vais prendre
les rênes de l'entrepreneuriat mais
parce que j'avais senti d'un puits de
mange annales j'ai cette capacité là
mais j'avais une éducation un peu
difficile
arrivées trouve à l'école on va dire
maintenant c'est l'expérience je joue
beaucoup sur l'expérience et il faut
dire le créole à la réunion nou lé kapab
nou lé kapab m'énerve beaucoup j'ose pas
à mon âge suis à tous dans le bâtiment
mais dont l'un bon potentiel ici
l'impressionnante choses extraordinaires
y en a un c'est que toutes les parties
ou vont faire mal parce qu'il ya six
mois ça me marchez pas aller aujourd'hui
qu'en me voir c'est les gens de juger
tout ce que micro malien silicone dans
ma colonne vertébrale simon dans la
tombe et échafaudages si un échelle
alors on y voit aujourd'hui d'arriver là
[Musique]
on va parler maintenant des jeunes des
jeunes créateurs
en effet les moins de 30 ans sont
peuvent bénéficier d'une subvention
le tarage on vous en parle tout de suite
j'appelle gene-h à vis d'un quartier du
moufia l'âge de 18 ans j'avais le goût
de partir à l'aventuré
donc je vais en profiter pour faire la
mobilité je partis au canada que y avait
des poutres heures qu'il y avait de la
bouffe de rue ça marchait bien
donc du coup j'ai voulu ramener ça c'est
là du coup que je parte ivoire conseil
général et j'ai appris qu'un bel étage
mais d'ici là il n'est pas dans nos
complexes
il ya des gens qui aident ce soit
chambre de commerce et si la bce a monté
le plan d'affaires ensemble et puis par
la suite elle m'a expliqué tous les
aides qu'ils pouvaient avoir dont le
tage qui était une subvention ce qui est
bien avec ses suivants sur la secal aide
les jeunes on n'est pas obligé de
rembourser donc c'est vraiment à une
subvention faut pousser les portes il
faut pas avoir peur
et puis quand les gens vous semble pas
motivé forcément il faut pas se
décourager il faut aller voir d'autres
personnes parce que chaque personne est
différente et vous allez finir par
trouver la bonne personne
il faut en leur projet
pas largués encore une belle expérience
un beau témoignage vous êtes dans
l'hémicycle du département pour la 19ème
édition du challenge des créateurs et
vous avez bien raison nous poursuivrons
cette grande édition par la catégorie
performance pour nous en parler donc
katy waro bonsoir vous êtes élu au
conseil régional de l'ordre des experts
comptables de quelle manière les experts
comptable accompagne les entreprises
locales dans nos cabinets
d'expertise-comptable nous accompagnons
les chefs d'entreprise à chaque étape de
leur développement
lorsqu'ils ont l'idée le l'idée du
projet la création de la société
dans le cas de leur développement lors
de la transmission de leur société nous
notre rôle d'expert comptable et de
pouvoir leur simplifier la vie en leur
proposant nous confier la réalisation de
toutes ses obligations légales fiscale
comptable sociale mais notre rôle notre
rôle est aussi au delà de ça de les
aider à prendre les bonnes décisions
en tout cas découvrons maintenant les
deux candidats en liste dans la
catégorie performance c'est parti
[Musique]
la performance et réussir à atteindre
ses objectifs en respectant les clips et
le client
je suis un challenger et j'aime les
défis et j'aime également innové
[Musique]
bienvenue donc sur l'exploitation de
yoland qu'est ce qui vous a amené à
faire ce métier de conseil aux
agriculteurs en fait j'ai fait des
études agricoles j'étais au lycée à
l'école de saint joseph dans quatre ans
je suis allé donc en métropole en 2009
fut rentré et j'ai commencé à imaginer
en fait ce projet est ce que ça a cru la
performance de cette exploitation votre
conseil produisent plus de tomates
utilisent moins d'intrants il n'utilise
plus d'insecticides et en général il ya
une meilleure cohésion au sein de leur
équipe et votre entreprise aujourd'hui
elle en est où
au niveau justement rentabilité et
chiffres qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'elle
donne au niveau du chiffre d'affaires
qu'on allait réaliser durant durant un
an et demi on est aux alentours des 300
mille euros on est également assez fier
d'avoir embauché une commerciale il ya
maintenant trois semaines
[Musique]
les agriculteurs avaient des besoins et
que le travail d'une subaru a permis de
répondre à ce beau à ce besoin et
d'augmenter la rentabilité la
performance des agriculteurs jm ancien
consulting représente pour moi une
entreprise effectivement relativement
performante et grâce à sa rentabilité
elle a réussi à employer de trois
personnes
il ya là des perspectives de
développement très intéressante au
niveau océan indien et internationaux
et
[Musique]
et vous avez quelle formation justement
avant de démarrer la création de votre
compte
alors j'avais un bachelor 1,12 bachelor
management touristique et management des
ressources humaines plus l'expérience
que j'avais eue en même temps à
l'étranger avec quatre concepts
principaux un bar à jus un bar à café
de quoi prendre un long break face toute
la journée et puis un repas de quoi
prendre un repas le midi salle et tout
est fait maison
alors est-ce que comment est ce que vous
vous estimez que votre entreprise et
performante et performante déjà de par
les réactions des clients qu'on a pour
l'instant le taux de captage intéressant
et le
globalement les gens sont quand même
très content amateurs de chiffres
d'affaires devait arriver à combien on
est déjà à ce qu'on attendait à une + 3
990 euros depuis qu'on a ouvert et vous
avez indochine quand même personne selon
navi salariés pour l'instant plus moi on
gérant non salarié nous c'est de pouvoir
être un acteur économique et culturel
local pour pouvoir créer une dynamique
entre touristes réunionnais puis à 6 en
2000 d'une entreprise qui à mon avis a
toutes les chances de perdurer et de se
développer
d'ailleurs il envisage déjà d'autres
points de vente dans des sites
historiques de l'île de la réunion
souhaite également utilisé beaucoup de
produits locaux et je pense que ça ça
peut être une belle réussite pour
marquer
[Musique]
encore de magnifiques candidats on peut
les applaudir ils sont là ah oui mais
vous féliciter schirrhein petit de
l'entreprise barista de bonbons gens
pouvaient continuer jean-marc hoareau
c'est le deuxième finaliste de
l'entreprise j aime t consulting
alors deux entreprises complètement
différent deux visions de la performance
complètement différente
le nom du finaliste et le vois bien
messieurs vainqueur du prix de la
performance 2016 est monsieur charles
frédéric petit pour la fonction super
félicitations au peuple applaudir c'est
le travail qui est récompensé
aujourd'hui
félicitations bravo bravo venez là c'est
une magnifique victoire
ça représente quoi vous voyez la
performance vous voulez partager ça oui
tout à fait et puis c'est un peu une
consécration il ya eu pas mal de
péripéties dans l'entrepreneuriat donc
le porteur de projet il faut qu'ils
soient motivés c'est sûr il faut surtout
que les élèves qu'il est la bonne
personne qui le porte puisque le projet
a besoin d'être porté donc merci à tous
ceux qui ont été là tant dans les
organismes qui avant projet puis surtout
ceux qui ont concrétisé l'idée sans qui
on n'aurait rien pu faire alors il ya
une personne qui veut qui a témoigné une
de vos salariés je vous propose
d'écouter son témoignage sur votre
participation challenge
[Musique]
parce que charest l'a beaucoup de da
sila il a tout lancé de az le concept a
et s est inspiré mais toutes les filles
de lui-même le dieu des travaux du début
jusqu'à - petit kiosque était posée la
facture donc je pense qu'elle est
beaucoup beaucoup de travail de sueur et
de labeur et il mérite va de gagner
parce que celle-ci nous a apporté le
concède mais aussi veut que chacun
d'entre nous à port de pêche n'a été
aussi angoissant c'est avance qu'en
cuisine vraiment très ouvert et c'est ça
qui est bien il est pas fermé les
appeler mon lycée
[Musique]
car le petit le mot de la fin c'est pour
vous vous avez envie de dire quoi au
créateur d'entreprise à ceux qui
n'auraient peut-être pas se lancer
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire
que comme l'a dit à leurs créole est
capable et il faut jamais baisser les
bras nous pousse paix
bravo félicitations bravo encore une
belle image
c'est magnifique une belle image de
créateurs de cette jeunesse qui bouge
des créateurs d'entreprise
alors pour l'instant trois lauréats
primés et vous vous demandez peut-être à
quoi ça sert de participer au challenge
des créateurs alors et surtout c'est à
quoi ça sert mais les deux planches avec
nous pour nous en parler karimama date
vous êtes directrice de la maison de
l'entreprise nord à la cci heures
exactement
alors quel est le rôle du réseau pour un
chance alors le réseau pour un champ
c'est un réseau d'accompagnement des
créateurs d'entreprise il est composé
donc des chambres consulaires chambre
des métiers chambre de commerce de la
boutique de gestion adèle d'initiative
réunion entreprendre et de la 10e pour
la partie financement est également en
émergence de projets de la couveuse
réussite et pour les projets qui se
développe dans les eaux de la d2r
l'association pour le développement
rural
terminons ces quelques mots sur le
réseau point chance par le témoignage
des anciens lauréats
ceux qui sont passés par le réseau point
chance et qui ont été accompagnés
[Musique]
l'accompagnement est très très important
ou une appellation parce que ça nous
permet d'avoir une base de travail de
consolider vraiment les dossiers avant
de déposer un mot ni matricule et son
entreprise la boutique de gestion la
chambre de métiers ça valait la peine
et comme moment-là démarré vers le
financement donc réunion entreprendre
été là pour apprendre le financement et
des mâts mon entreprise parce que ma
investi quand même dans des machines à
bois dans ma vie prennent atelier
machines à bois à thiviers et la malade
puis démarrer doucement doucement
annoncé comme les autres au début tout
seul et essayer de se débrouiller et on
a très vite compris en fait il vaut
mieux monter une équipe surtout sur des
projets à l'export comme celui-là sur
lequel on travaille aujourd'hui et avoir
des gens qualifiés pour vous aider dans
tous les domaines qu'on ne maîtrise pas
en fait
moi j'étais un technicien je connaissais
plutôt la partie technique on a besoin
quand on est une société d'avoir tous
les autres domaines que ce soit
l'administratif ou aujourd'hui on a un
responsable qualité
on a au sein d'entreprises différents
départements et on est obligé de
s'entourer pour faire ça on peut pas le
faire tout seul retour dans l'hémicycle
du département et nous poursuivons cette
19ème édition du challenge par le prix
de l'innovation
[Musique]
pour nous en parler myriam boullay vous
êtes élu à la cci hier vous nous avez
rejoint l'innovation c'est un joli
moment il c'est beau l'innovation mais
en la réalité c'est qu'il faut produire
il faut rentrer des sous dans
l'entreprise est-ce qu'il faut donner de
cette place à l'innovation dans
l'entreprise
alors je pense que l'année est donc tout
à fait faire les deux et surtout on doit
faire les deux c'est pas qu'on peut
c'est qu'on doit faire les deux
maintenant quand on parle d'innovation
on a toujours tendance à se dire waouh
il faut trouver l'idée du siècle il faut
trouver l'idée que personne n'a eue qui
va nous rapporter un maximum d'argent et
si possible en travaillant fort en
travaillant moins possible bref c'est
pas toujours le cas
l'innovation c'est se poser pour se
poser il faut savoir parfois lâcher
prise il faut réfléchir et il faut se
dire que innover c'est peut-être tout
simplement repenser sa façon de
travailler c'est pas forcément et s'y
est trouvé l'idée du siècle
c'est peut-être rependre savoir penser
sa façon de travailler
repenser la façon de travailler ses
collaborateurs les écouter surtout les
écouter et de l'ain on va gagner du
temps de paix elle a gagné d'art vivante
voilà on va se poser on va écouter les
autres
on va s'écouter soi même ça aussi c'est
important est peut-être qu'on écoutant
les autres tout simplement et en
s'écoutant soi même on va la trouver
cette idée de génie peut-être alors
c'est ce que vous avez entendu le
conseil donner du sens à votre pratique
si c'est bien ça donc deux finalistes je
vous propose maintenant qu'on
s'intéresse aux deux finalistes à ces
deux candidats dans la catégorie de
l'innovation c'est parti
[Musique]
l'innovation c'est pour nous l'essence
même de notre projet
[Musique]
la compétition en tant que les règles
sont respectées c'est une bonne chose
[Musique]
et
et eux
[Musique]
bonjour sur série bonjour messieurs
jérôme qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à
créer cette entreprise innovante
aujourd'hui pendant les études j'avais
eu envie de créer une entreprise
j'ai commencé à travailler dans
l'industrie pendant sept années dans
différents secteurs sport automobile en
france en angleterre différentes
industries principalement pour des
marchés export en arrivant à la réunion
je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
envie de faire bouger les choses et
développer un nouveau produit pour
répondre à certaines problématiques
notamment celles de trafic urbain
souhaité prendre les avantages du vélo
et les avantages de la voiture et
développer un nouveau type de véhicule
donc on a développé un triporteur cargo
caréné à énergie photovoltaïque qui
permet de pouvoir se déplacer livrer des
marchandises dans les centres-villes ou
déplacer des personnes sur des distances
allant jusqu'à 60 km
[Musique]
toute crise il ya une opportunité et le
chômage peut peut en être une qui permet
de pouvoir créer son activité si on le
souhaite depuis depuis longtemps la
participation au challenge est une est
une chance ça donne un crédit
complémentaire pour un projet outre-mer
et et nous permet d'avoir également une
visibilité pour pouvoir parler nous fait
rêver et essayer de changer changer
notre société progressivement deux
étapes entreprises innovantes qui a su
allier technologie nouvelles
technologies et développement durable
bien nous en tant qu il sera comptable
on trouve que ce projet quand même et
viable et donc à les chances de réussite
[Musique]
et
bienvenue à l'usiné c'est ici qu'on a
installé les bureaux de data rock et je
vous invite à venir voir pour ma part
j'ai fait la majeure partie de mes
études à la réunion je suis parti en
métropole et en rentrant la réunion
c'est un peu un alignement des étoiles
comme on dit on était aussi sur la
révolution au big data comment on fait
pour vivre
or deux ans que je suis à faire comment
on fait pour ce geste est un autre choix
c'était de dire on bénéficie du chômage
on va utiliser cet argent à nous pour
travailler sur notre produit ce qui a
fait qu'on a réussi à voir maintenir une
rémunération le temps de la recherche et
développement et après au moment où on a
commercialisé passé les clients qui ont
réussi à reprendre le relais
bienvenue à datarock ce jeu présente
valérie et laurent qui sont mes associés
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les entreprises et
collectivités génère de plus en plus de
données donc on peut sans logiciel de
création de tableaux baroques va
permettre de créer des tables bloc sur
la fois très design mais aussi
interactive et là où on a vraiment
apporté nous de l'innovation c'est à la
fois sur cette partie visuelle et
interactif mais aussi sur la partie
création des tables d'europe
on n'est pas sûr de l'innovation de
rupture on n'a pas créé quelque chose de
nouveau on en est sûr plus haut sur
l'innovation d'usagé de donner la
possibilité de créer créer des tableaux
de bord il n'y a pas de raison pour
qu'on n'y arrive pas aussi à la réunion
donc c'est un vrai message d'espoir ma
part la jeunesse rennaise qui est le
numérique et l'entrepreneuriat alors
c'est un outil magique qu'ils ont reçues
a développé un outil indispensable pour
tous managers ou chef d'entreprise je
relève aussi le parcours de monsieur
narayanin qui a mis à profit une période
de chômage pour développer son projet et
le mener à bien
[Musique]
encore des beaux portée de magnifiques
créateurs ils sont là dans la zone de
délibérations alors on fait durer le
suspense
deux bons candidats qui représente
l'innovation et peut-être les idées de
génie
nous verrons si cela peut être déjà
alors le prix de l'innovation remis par
la cci est attribué à monsieur arnaud
rolland jean chéreau l'applaudît hélas
sas
on peut l'applaudir s'évalue si arnaud
cherokee développe avec ses entreprises
vélo triporteur
on développe un triporteur cargo
alimenté par l'énergie photovoltaïque de
manière à réduire l'impact en gaz
carbonique de nos déplacements chez un
copain qui fait partie de cette
dynamique start up
je te propose de l'écouter
[Musique]
et
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours une idée
pertinente et ça s'arrête pas là parce
que du coup c'est quelqu'un qui a une
capacité d'exécution vraiment importante
enfin mon avis c'est une des personnes
clés de l'écosystème start up sur l'île
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive à voir au
final une vision assez globale et tout
ce qui se passe sur le territoire et de
ses fêtes il y là arrivent facilement à
à centraliser et du coup arrêt donner
les informations donc à mettre en
relation facilement les gens quoi
quelqu'un a besoin d'un truc assez
précis il a tout de suite dans sa tête
une cartographie assez claire de ce qui
se passe est du coup en mettant en
relation les gens de manière naturelle
c'est rare sur la personne avec ses
profits de là à mon avis sur les
territoires l'innovation ça coûte cher
qu'est-ce que ça va changer de gagner ce
prix là alors on en parle est
effectivement une visibilité un soutien
financier également pour pouvoir acheter
des outillages complémentaires comme
vous le disiez l'innovation c'est
quelque chose de long qui nécessite des
financements mais on a de la chance
d'être sur un territoire où les
différents acteurs travaillent ensemble
et ça génère une synergie qui nous est
d'autant plus vis-à-vis de futurs
concurrents européens et internationaux
[Musique]
je vous propose de passer maintenant au
prix du produit pays
[Musique]
pour nous parler du produit perry c'est
un représentant de la chambre
d'agriculture qui nous a rejoint que la
règle d'un bonsoir bonsoir
alors c'est quoi le produit pays le pro
du pays s'est montrée à la réunion qu'on
a un savoir-faire montrer qu'on peut
faire des choses traditionnelles montrer
qu'on est capable à la réunion de
produire avec des produits qui sont ici
à la réunion de transformer devant et
surtout de mettre en l'air
l'île de la réunion alors vous étiez sur
le terrain avec nous on à découvrir avec
vous les finalistes de la fidh et les
finalistes donc je crois que eux ils
défendent vraiment le produit p
[Musique]
si je gagne ce sera ça sera vraiment un
grand honneur
ça sera une reconnaissance de mon
travail
c'est vrai j'ai pas fais de la
compétition j'abandonne jamais
[Musique]
non
du coup de genou un peu secrète parcours
alors mon parcours professionnel m'a
fait deux ans une formation aux 17,3 est
né voulait valoriser justement le
terrain agricole du patrimoine que nous
n'avez est aussi montré que ben laden à
mon ip capable de travailler si un
produit comme plante à la russie alors
amis essayent de mettre les produits
pays en avant parce que pour moi les
impotents très important que nous remet
tout ça on va lui s'il proposait les
anciens légumes qui dit songe manioc
on a les bras de choix aussi comme
talent un entraîneur pas être comment
cultiver avec un fumier est produit
c'est comment on fait alors moi même on
allait agriculture raisonnée parfois
même du bio parce qu'on a des endroits
où par exemple les poireaux n'y fait
aucun traitement phytosanitaire du sud
[Musique]
déjà l'importation d'entre elles tuent à
nous ça allait très importants produits
péi mange pays
[Musique]
ça peut servir d'exemple à des personnes
qui ont un petit bout de tes à quoi s'en
sortir et pour rentrer dans la vie
active
c'est un petit bout de femme donc elle a
mis tous les éléments nécessaires qu'il
fallait à son installation
donc je pense qu'elle s'est battue et
jusqu'au bout je pense que l'arbre c'est
l'aboutissement de quelque chose qu'elle
attend je pense de pigalle
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour bienvenue chez coco
patients et en même temps chez moi je
vais vous présenter mon entreprise donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler de
votre parcours
j'ai démarré mon activité au moment où
mes enfants ont quitté un peu la maison
je m'étais occupé d'eux depuis qu'on est
habité la réunion et au moment où le
dernier est parti mais les choses se
sont faites tout seul puisque la passion
des fruits de la passion et la passion
des confitures m'a amené à créer mon
activité
[Musique]
du coup vous approvisionner
loin d'ici ou non non un général voilà
c'est vraiment les producteurs de
l'ouest
bon après pour ce qui est du brouillard
et des letchis sebag ouest bon je
travaille uniquement des fruits qui sort
ou en agriculture bio ou raisonnée
c'est à partir du moment où on met des
produits de qualité c'est pas difficile
de faire beau et c'est ce que ce que
j'essaie de faire quand on a envie de
vivre passionnément ce qu'on aime faire
il faut il faut une fois les esprits
mais pour peut-être pas avoir peur des
gens voient que c'est une entreprise qui
utilise beaucoup de pros du pays et qui
met en valeur pour avoir au final un
produit de qualité de haute qualité
donc c'est un bébé pour elle nous on va
dire une nouvelle un nouveau départ dans
la vie
donc elle a su trouver les financements
qu'il fallait pour pouvoir s'installer
[Musique]
elles sont là tous les deux créatrices
deux entrepreneuses de mère de famille
on peut les applaudir encore claret quoi
là c'est vous qui allez annoncer c'est
pas facile non on est sûr qu'il y aura
une gagnante
oui rover je vous laisse nous annoncer
le lauréat
la gagnante pour le prix pays
c'est madame muriel eddy lebon on peut
l'applaudir
muriel le pont des entreprises les bons
fruits et légumes
on a l'impression que vous prenez toutes
les difficultés avec le souriant mais
say say say puisque les pas facile le
soin commune avant de dormir quand même
est tracassé ne monte pas personne mais
très difficile ce métier la leggia faut
dire les dieux lever le matin me fais
les marchés mais réveille à 2 heures du
matin on va les vendre mes produits
immédiate que les miss aube à témoin
sera toujours la même
muriel on a demandé à ta famille
pourquoi tu méritais de gagner ce prix
voilà c'est une battante au fait ses
études
c'était pas une mince affaire il fallait
gérer les enfants les études que c'est
un métier pas facile dans ces métiers
d'hommes et et comme l'agriculture de sa
passion bon me dit bon écoute si
vraiment on veut et a pas de souci vas-y
foncé et commerce est quelqu'un de
tenace le pc vers on est motivé il n'y a
pas de souci et vas-y les français ah
oui absolument fia fille adèle et elle a
obtenu ses diplômes à la cuisse à son du
jury pour moi c'est une fierté
pensée plurielle que ça votr lac les
enfants quand ils vous voient comme ça
c'est un botteur obligé c'est ma ma vie
c'est ma raison d'être chaque joueur
c'est ce qui motive à moi tous les jours
et même mon mari me motive à moins
[Musique]
alors c'est déjà la dernière catégorie
le prix du jury
[Musique]
alors pour nous présenter cette
catégorie prix du jury la présidente du
département nous a rejoints parce que
vous passez un bon moment oui même si
j'ai eu une longue et votre journée de
travail je passe un bon moment se sent
pas devoir de créateurs grâce à vous
tous parce que vous êtes vraiment des
réunionnais formidable peu les applaudir
c'est vrai c'est vrai ils ont fait
passer une bonne soirée
alors que je vous propose maintenant
c'est de découvrir les finalistes de la
catégorie prix du jury
[Musique]
je préfère plutôt gagné quand même
un président à bonbons
bienvenue
ça ne dégage aucune ambiance chaleureuse
on est vers merci c'était c'est le but
en fait de l'épicerie on voulait revenir
un épicier de proximité demandez vous
mesurez donc le risque est donc est pris
cette décision donc de franchir le pas
j'ai toujours été dans le commerce donc
j'ai toujours eu un contact avec avec
les gens j'aime beaucoup ça c'est
vraiment ma passion donc pour du riz
complet
et voilà
pouvez nous parler un petit peu de la
performance de votre commerce mais on
est vraiment au dessus de notre
prévisionnel donc le palais le pari le
challenge et il est il est gagné des
personnes qui habitent dans le sud
partout sur dix nous demandent vraiment
de d'ouvrir ce genre de magasin un petit
peu partout sur l'île j'ai réussi à
créer de l'emploi
je m'insère bien ça ça marche très bien
et en plus on fait du bien la planète
de plus en plus les producteurs pays se
mettent à l'agriculture biologique à la
réunion donc nous on est là en tant
qu'entreprise pour encourager
ces producteurs à mettre leurs produits
en avant cette entreprise est bluffant
qui a vraiment tout pour réussir
le concept est très original fait de
pouvoir permettre à chacun d'entre nous
dire de consommer justement on a besoin
c'est un projet très intéressant
[Musique]
donc voila mon bureau qui faisait office
de chambre et de deux salles de travail
benjamin donc peut tout nous expliquer
ton parcours professionnel un parcours
professionnel il est assez court budget
que les 26 ans
moi j'ai fait une grande école de
commerce sur paris il ya c'est paris
cependant cinq ans après une classe
préparatoire abbé pierre à la réunion
donc à la fin de cette école à lui se
spécialise en entrepreneuriat
[Musique]
tu peux nous expliquer ton concept et
comment être qu'il démarre dans la rue
comment comment faire et bien là on est
sur la possession va faire la balade
spectacle sur les traces des vaillants
champs et vergers roston donc le concept
des balades créative vous aider
découvert très insolites du patrimoine
culturel de l'île par l'intermédiaire de
spectacle vivant
donc c'est des gens de balades
culturelles sont mises en scènes animées
par des artistes vappereau pour immerger
les gens la culture de l'île c'est une
aventure merveilleuse on vit son rêve ou
du matin au soir
les fonds n'arrivent pas dormi on se
comprend c'est tellement assas et c'est
juste génial pour moi pour l'instant il
ya eu la bonne idée effectivement donc
le public et alerte captivé donc parce
que racontant que les compteurs c'est
viable parce qu'en fait le réunionnais a
besoin de retrouver sa culture et de
retrouver en fait ses origines et ses
racines
[Musique]
bravo bravo à tous les deux nelly
fontaine de la société wokup benjamin
clément des balades créative vous êtes
dans la zone de délibérations je vous
laisse annoncé le lauréat
madame la présidente prix du jury a été
attribué à monsieur benjamin clément
robeau publication benjamin des balades
créative une réaction à cette récompense
voisins c'est c'est génial c'est une
consécration de tout un travail travail
en équipe avec des artistes formidables
un travail qui est soutenue par la
famille les amis et moi c'est mon reste
dans mes tripes donc c'est juste génial
au début du sujet tu nous parler de ta
maman justement nous a confié son
sentiment sur ta démarche créative
[Musique]
tous
son but était de rendre à la réunion ce
que l'oreille en mire d'un portique
voilà c'est une des choses qui m'a dit
en revenant décidant de s'installer
depuis deux ans il ne consacre sa vie
qu'à ça et là pendant un an et s'est
battu pour que ça en entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent agréé déjà ça a été
tout un parcours du combattant
parce que c'est très dur quand on
commence pour les jeunes à trouver des
aides à trouver des entreprises des
prêts et tout il est parti vraiment de
zéro et a un peu tendance à en faire à
sa tête mais comme il croit qu'il est
persuadé qu'il a raison dont je
comprends tout à fait voilà on voit trop
de jeunes qui sont un peu défaitiste et
je trouve que quelqu'un comme lui qui
ose croire en ses rêves et cd réalisé
jusqu'au bout je consomme merveilleux
voilà fiers de leur fils
je lui remets ce prix j'ai envie de dire
comme a comme vienne le dia sa maman il
croit en ses rêves et puis il croit en
son île et à la culture de son île et ça
c'est formidable parce que c'est un
atout extraordinaire nous avons notre
identité c'est au fond le plus bel atout
de la réunion c'est la matière humaine
c'est à dire c'est le réunionnais lui
même bravo encore fait une petite place
aux
[Musique]
l'émission se termine merci au réseau
point chance d'avoir animé les servies
avec le service économie solidaire et
tous ses partenaires
un grand bravo à l'équipe de 9 7 4 tv
qui a entièrement produit ses reportages
pouvait les applaudir
mes calculs veiller à la réalisation et
visualiser la technique
emmanuel richard à l'infographie toute
la dream team de 9 sec 81 nous respirons
vous avez compris l'esprit c'est à vous
de jouer
bonne soirée et à bientôt
[Musique]